(whooshing)
- [Evan] What connects your happiness?
Everything you do is connected
to who you are as a person
and, in turn, creates the
person you are becoming.
Paul E. Miller, author known
for his books on spirituality.
This is where the magic starts to happen.
You have your page of all the things
that make you happy, right?
If not, do it now, it's important.
Go back and watch that video,
I want you to take action.
There is one common theme that connects
all the things that make you happy.
You might have many reasons why
Mrs. Jones was your favorite teacher.
There could be 10 things you
love about your favorite movie.
The people you hang out with
have lots of different personalities.
But there is one theme
that unites them all.
One thing they together share.
This is a connective tissue that will make
all your future decisions easier.
This is the powerful
mantra that will give you
a sense of purpose and help you
change the world for the better.
This is your one word.
Find the common theme
in the list of things
that make you happy and write it down.
If it doesn't pop off the page,
then next to each of the
things that make you happy,
write why you like it.
You'll notice a pattern that emerges.
Some words will come
up over and over again.
Take the words you've used most commonly
to describe your happiest moments,
and group them together.
If you can't get it down to
one word yet, don't worry.
Just try to get the final
list from this exercise
down to five words or fewer.
Now we can take the next step in building
your extraordinary life and business.
(whooshing)